I am smart capable and most importantly  I'm free in all the ways that you are  not Brad Pitt is free to create art yeah  it's good it was really good it's good  time following Brad's split from  Angelina Jolie in September it seems the  53 year old actor is channeling his  energy into sculpture and eyewitness  tells ET brad has been locking himself  away in an art studio sometimes up to 15  hours a day here's the Fight Club star  arriving at the studio via motorcycle  the father of six kept his look casual  of flannel jeans and sunglasses are  eyewitness says brad off and listens to  sad songs when he's in creative mode by  artists like Bon Iver and Waylon  Jennings Brad on a motorcycle Brad  sculpting art we love it all it's a real  pleasure  you